hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've just decided guys to create my
youtube channel
i want to discuss here everything i do
at work
all the tools and techniques that i use
to make money on the markets
so in today's video i want to make an
update on fubu and show you guys what i
see let's get into it
[Music]
let's start with the chart on the
forward time frame as usual guys the
chart where
you do the time frame we're gonna have
the best reactions
so let's analyze what is happening guys
for the past month
i was making regular updates so just as
a reminder so fubu
tv went to 60 and now is trading at 19
so it lost
around 65 percent of what it was worse
a few months ago so let's try first to
understand if this move is finished or
not and what created this move and
what are the different outcomes that can
happen now
so the first thing guys i want to remind
you that uh here
you know i was actually bearish guys i
was making you know some updates around
this level that was telling you guys
i'm bearish because i know that
corrections
usually happen in three waves a b c
and here i was only having you know a
and maybe a b
so i was bearish here and then i turned
bullish
here at the 20 level because i showed
you guys many times how i find this
long term support that is now resistance
but i'm gonna
go back to it very soon and then yeah so
i was here bullish and i was
trying to find some bullish signals
under
short term and i was guys seeing
here you know a small triangle that got
broken on the upside with the very
strong volume so guys
it was the perfect situation you know in
this kind of situation
like 95 and that's let's say 90
of the times you know you have the
continuation of the price action in the
direction of the breakout
here though we came back we didn't have
the support
i was expecting at the 20 level we broke
20
uh on the daily time frame and we
confirmed guys all right we confirmed so
on the daily time frame because
this is good to watch on the daily
timeframe as well guys it's like
long-term movements
we have the breakouts and we confirmed
so thursday breakout
friday we confirm we close below 20 and
it's not very close to it
it's really below it so the breakout is
clean
and it's confirmed so it's not good for
the short term
but once again guys uh when you have
this type of situation
it's you know giving you good signals
eighty percent of the times you know
around like a confirmed
breakouts usually gives you eighty
percent of the time
the direction where the price action
would keep going
but here i want to show you something
else guys so
there are many things i want to show you
so i'm just going to do them one by one
and try not to forget anything so the
first thing
is that you know i like to use trend
lines so and when i do my trend line
here you see guys i just connect the
lowest level of fubu
at three i have one low here one low
here i connect
those two guys and you can see i'm very
close to this one
and i'm actually right on this one all
right so this is a bit of hope
that i'm having when i see this you know
it's just telling me that
actually we have a support level this is
a long term uh support
guys you know because i'm using like
very inch like
not very recent data i'm using june 19
data so almost uh 18 months and
so it's a long term support and when you
have a long-term support that is coming
here
so i had one here as well all right but
like i said guys this one could have
been put
at different places let's go back to
how i found this one i found this one i
was just using you know the highs that i
had here
and you can see for example so i was
using this high
this high this one this one you know and
all this area
you know so between 23 and actually the
lowest one
is this one here and this one is
at 18.3 so you know there is still a bit
of hope
that actually fugu is bottoming but
clearly the odds are against us this
area
was actually holding a support for two
weeks
and it broke so you know something was
missing something happened in this
market
that i cannot explain and when i dig
a bit i have a bit of explanation so let
me show you what i found
i just use you know as usual guys you're
going market watch
market beat whatever and you have all
this information
you have the equity float the
outstanding number of shares
the short interest and you can from that
compute
uh the public shares and the short
interest so you can see for example that
fubu
has 85 percent of its float share that
is public
15 is managed by non-active fund
managers
or it's just detained by the owners
of the company so they cannot basically
exit their shares without making it
public but whatever
what is interesting here guys is to
notice what happened between
the 15th of march and the 15th of april
so basically
in the last month you can see that
basically football emitted a lot of
shares guys all right it emitted now we
have 118 million shares
when we had here so they emitted 35
of additional shares compared to the
float they had on the 15th of march
so this should mechanically lower the
price by 35 percent
you know the same way
by actually the price should lose uh 27
you know it should be multiplied by 0.73
i just
inverted this so we should see a loss of
23
make it mechanically and what happened
between the 15th of march
here and the 15th of april guys this
massive move down
only 16 so it's actually you know less
than we should have seen so once again
guys
you know there is always a reason here
the reason why we probably
broke the 20 level the reason why we
were going down
here that severely is not because people
are bearish is because the company is
in desperate need of cash and they emit
a lot of shares
you know 35 is not joke guys it's like
really a lot and of course it's gonna
have an impact on the
uh stock price so now at least we know
what is happening what is happening
is not hedge funds attacking football
you can see that the short interest
is rather stable around 18 million of
shares
so rather stable especially in the last
month it didn't move
so it's not hedge funds attacking
football which is
good news because when you have hedge
funds against you
it's not you know good news here is the
company itself
that is putting pressure on the stock
price but you know
you don't emit shares when the price is
actually not high usually you wait for
the price to be high so
around this levels it is very
understandable that they emit shares
because
they prefer to raise money through
equity than raising money through cash
because the cash would cost them the
interest rate and they can
you know lock some good levels because
the stock price is high
here guys i mean you know the stock
price is not high
it's not that low you know it's like
much higher than it used to be
but it's not high so i i doubt they
would keep
putting this pressure on the price so on
the medium term
it's for me it's good signals because
it's not hedge funds attacking the
company so
it's easier for the company to actually
just have better results and for the
price action
to revert and start to make higher lows
and higher highs
but here uh one more thing i wanted to
tell you
yeah so this abc that i
have here is complete guys but once
again it can go
here it would be the same thing so we
are wondering
what can happen here so let me get rid
of it we are wondering
how low we can go so you can see that
for example
we used to have for example here some
fake breakouts guys this is
once again this is something very usual
very common
that is happening around 20 maybe 30 of
the times when you have a confirmed
breakout
and how is it working guys how long is
actually the price
staying above your trend line you can
see here an example so let's go to the
daily time frame
one two three four five even less
four days all right so fake breakouts
don't last long
so once again if we need to come back
here at this level
it would be it would probably
come back quickly so next week would be
very important i have some hope that
actually the long-term support level is
here and not here
because this was an area and this is the
lowest level i can find in this area
so basically if we break this
lowest level that is 18 and if we don't
see
you know a reversal next week then
probably we're going lower
and my next support level
so once again guys i try to find some
you know i use the same method i try to
find some highs in the recent past and
some consolidation so here for example i
have a
consolidation clearly you see one two
three four
five days no it's not days it's four
hours but like a few
days it was just concentrating around
this level
i have a high here i have a high here so
i know that this is probably going to be
a level where i'm going to find support
so basically here is the situation guys
either we have a quick rebound and we
trade
above the 20 level very soon and it's
good
like within the next week or we don't we
go probably lower and then
the scenario that might happen is that
you know we do something like this
and we go here and then we finally we
come back
we go here and then we go so all right
in the
long term guys it's a stock price of
course it's bullish
i mean we've seen some very low levels
so we're gonna analyze the situation
around this level but this correction
must stop at a time you know so an abc
like this would be
already a very strong abc so then we
would probably have
some correction in the correction so at
least come back to the 20 level and here
you guys
can still take a decision you guys can
exit your stock if you don't like it
so you're gonna have one more chance
around this level almost
100 sure even if we go to 15 we're gonna
at least come back here
you know before going lower you know
this
could be as well a scenario but
coming back to the 20 level is something
that
we will see probably before june
whatever
the situation so you're gonna have uh
one more opportunity to take a decision
that is going to be very important
around this level so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys